Samuel leaves here and I have the
absolute pleasure to introduce the one
and only mr. Trevor cut more hi how you
doing good man good to have you on the
channel named Trevor be mates ages he is
a absolute lease option agreement King
so we're just gonna be talking about
lease option agreement some how you can
buy property using not not only not
using any money but without even having
to borrow money from anybody you can you
can do this brilliant strategy and we're
gonna be just brainstorming about it
talking to Trevor when did we first meet
Oh probably about five years ago product
five years so we've known each other and
we've had you speaking at reigning kings
events you're now running a session with
our Academy members why don't you just
kick off with a little bit of background
about yourself Trevor who are you and
why are you so good well well I started
as a chef in London I was 25 years I
worked in Italian restaurants doing a
rich and famous went out to Italy to
work hard hard life yeah
but I very much enjoyed it but having a
young family that was very painful
because didn't see them and then I
really wanted to do something to put
back into other people's lives I had a
bit of a conversion I came to a
Christian faith and that really changed
good decision it really did a massive
massive change in my life and it saved
my marriage but from there what happened
is I just had this thing I wanted to do
to help people so I gave up my job I
took a 2/3 salary cut and the flat in
Knightsbridge which they gave me which
you can see Harrods from yeah and I went
to work for a charity doing community
development work and I remember summer
the first time I started in the week of
2003 I think it was someone yeah and I
went straight away for a European social
funding training day to learn of how to
deliver it remember I was a chef I
hadn't even used a computer for donkey's
years yeah and when I sat down someone
the trainer said was talking and talking
and said the bouncer smes so I put my
hand up and I said excuse me can you
tell me what an SME is and everyone
laughed which is a smaller medium
enterprise
and but I didn't care because I knew I
had a thirst for knowledge so no matter
what other people are gonna think I was
gonna learn yeah and so what I did I
pushed on in there
and I really enjoyed the community
development work I did that for nearly
10 just short of 10 years and we went
out into the streets met gangs got
invited to gangs because I learned how
to talk with them I fought for Great
Britain in martial arts and so Wow
they love to talk about things like that
but over two and a half year period we
reduced crime by 85% and we dissolved
the gangs and that was fantastic that's
what I really like yeah doing that was
my heart really now the thing is is that
although I bought some property with the
business partner back in 2006 7 I think
it was in the crash we had four
properties down at Cornwall it was a con
and really we were in trouble so is sink
or swim and my training in property
really started I would say about 2008 9
yeah and then I learned and I went to
learn options specifically because he
was sink or swim so how do you get a lot
of properties quickly what was it that
attracted you about lease options
win-win yes
so look if I come and buy your house and
it's a it's half a million I'll give you
four hundred thousand thank you very
much but let's suppose in now that I
come along and I see your your house in
its half a million pounds and one way
you can use an option this way but there
supposing that I see an opportunity and
for 50,000 pounds investment I could put
in a new kitchen new bathroom perhaps a
loft extension do it you know a good bit
of work for fifty thousand pounds and I
wouldn't even have to raise that 50 I'll
tell you about that in a second but now
it's suddenly worth 650 well now I can
pay you 550 I get my 50 grand back and
there's 50 thousand for me thank you
very much yeah now imagine if I found a
builder who would do that fifty thousand
pounds worth of work if I was to give
him half of that profit so he makes 25
grand on top of his 50 now with no money
at all I've just made myself
five thousand pounds yeah and more
importantly the vendor is really happy
because not only have they hit their
asking price they've got so much more
but that's one of honestly thousands of
different yeah why don't you perhaps
loving the story that background is
brilliant I love your heart but for
anyone watching who doesn't know what a
lease option agreement is or they're
just like what on earth is it what why
don't you summarize what that is okay
look basically if I can borrow a sheet
of paper yeah a lease option let me show
it to you is that it is a blank piece of
paper it will be a legal agreement that
a vendor let's say you've got a house
and I'm an investor and we make an
agreement that I will buy your house
over a period of time let's say five
years yep it's a it's a hundred thousand
pounds okay and we've agreed I'm going
to buy it for 5 in 5 years time four
hundred thousand pounds now really
important with a purchase lease option
the vendor nor his family can stay in
that property while you got that
contract running yeah okay correct now
before that you want something for that
so I'm going to buy it in five years
time for a hundred thousand pounds
you've got a mortgage so I'm gonna rent
your property out but I'm also going to
pay you something whatever that is that
might just cover that mortgage it might
be 70 75 percent of the rent now I won't
have to go and get consent to let
because if it's your personal home
you've moved out we need permission from
the mortgage lender in order that we can
use as a rental property yeah okay so
that's really important and even if you
haven't have that consent to let you
still can't do as a multi let unless you
get the permission yeah so look at that
because there are a lot of people in the
market that try to do this under hand
they do breach mortgage terms more
importantly you're breaching insurance
and there's just no need there's no need
do it properly or don't do it at all yep
okay so in five years time anytime in
that five years time I can sell in that
property the contract will be assignable
so I don't actually have to buy it
myself I can put it on the open market
and I can sell it so supposing in five
years time I sell it for 120,000 you get
your hundred I'm eight twenty plus I've
made a little bit of money along the way
so they've got exactly what they wanted
exactly
you've made a load of money without
putting down any money at all and you've
probably got some cash flow each month
as well yes yeah look the most important
thing Samuel which Pete a lot of people
miss on it isn't no money at all you
must use solicitors and their solicitors
will have a cost and that does run in if
you're paying the vendors fees as well
then that's going to cost you probably a
couple of thousand pounds or not far
short of that all right yes I think it's
about 700 I pay around about 750 yeah
plus Lister plus fat yeah plus fat okay
and so normally you know when you're
getting start you're not backwards dude
correct that's fair enough then you know
so if you if you put that in but still
if you if you've bought a house and
you're getting rent from it caps
depreciation from it and all you've paid
is to lots of 750 plus that it's not bad
not bad at all no in fact I'd say very
very good
he takes it no it really is yeah really
yes and you know I've loved helping
people and the people's motivation
for taking on an option because it is
not for everyone you can't go to houses
and view and think oh push option option
of course not now I know so let me ask
you a question in each other how do you
find properties that are suitable for
lease option agreements well I do
several things one of them are
advertised in the newspaper yeah look at
newspaper adverts I look at properties
which have renting which are trying to
rent whether on gumtree
are the classified ads and I'll ring
them directly today we're going to be
doing some of that yeah I would drive
around an area I'll make a note of every
property in distress and then I would go
online and I will bide the title deed so
I can get the address of the owner I
would send a post a letter to that
person and see if I can get engaged with
them yeah and see if this is something
now that may not even be a lease option
might be just a purchase option where I
get the chance to buy it up lift it like
I said adding value and then we sell it
yeah okay and then I I am a bit of let's
say somebody puts themselves about so I
am known quite a lot people know what I
do and I talk about what I do so yeah I
got one in a supermarket in the same
specific oh my tomato is it a guy stuck
in this
often some God just said to excuse me he
not looking to sell your house on your
you know whatever and he did and he
ended up as a lease option for me that's
incredible it was great that is
incredible
so what would you say to somebody then
who said buying properties we've no
money down and all this lease option
agree with its it just sounds too good
to be true I think it I think surely
it's a scam you're making it sound too
good I mean what would you say to
someone that said that I understand why
you say is it a scam or too good to be
true I understand that but the truth is
is that if you kiss enough frogs you're
gonna find that prints okay and options
are there they're not for everyone and
I've seen people who get very
disheartened when you say they're not
for everyone you mean they're not for
every seller not for every investor no
that's well every investor should we do
these objects at all in the toolbox yes
that's what it is
exactly look you know I'm currently
buying five more houses at the minute
and buying those but every one I go and
see are weighed up and I listen the ears
of the single most important tools you
have an option yeah because when you
hear what the vendors wants to do that
opens a door okay and then you can bring
out the tall of the option yeah and
that's the great thing about it so it's
not for every vendor it is something
that I believe every investor if they
want to maximize their income and
maximize their profits then they should
know yeah how they work yeah but this is
very doable that she's very legit not
only are you doing it successfully and I
doing this successfully but many of our
students are yes and it's a very doable
approach I so wonderful so what would
you what would you say to someone that
was wanting to start out and learn about
and pursue Lease Option agreements what
were their first steps to get trained by
reputable people yeah all right I have
seen some terrible trainers out there
giving terrible advice alright some of
that advice would be make your own
contracts that is a no-no yeah no no
because then it then if it ends up going
to court you lost everything yeah you
could and then you've suddenly you might
not have invested any money but for the
sake of a thousand pounds or two you've
now yeah you've now you've now lost all
the equity in the property you've lost
all the
that you would have got yeah yeah
totally okay so get trained get trained
it must must learn from people who are
doing it yeah I'm doing it well yeah I
agree
so what happened then until you started
smashing it out you learn about property
you stop buying deals then what yeah
I've continued I did have a business
partner unfortunately that business with
a relationship broke down and so about
two years ago something like that about
two years ago we separated yeah and I
walked away with not much at all
I think I ended up with about four
properties of which I sold one
straightaway and had three for two years
ago you know three houses lesson yeah
yeah and now we just completed on the
19th one do you know what that's amazing
so in two years you've gone from three
hat
so you lost pretty much everything yeah
and you went from three houses barely
yeah so now 19 yeah profitable lucrative
houses yeah yeah and these are all
purchases so with the options
I don't count options I'm very much now
a short-term option guy so I want I'm
looking for the properties that I can
add value make cash yeah take it back
out and then with that cash I paid my
tax and then I use the deposit to buy
another property in my portfolio that's
great so that's right
so and the thing is you said it before
it's part of the toolbox in its lease
option agreements is not something that
you should just have on its own and go
and try and make it fit with people's
houses you should become a an investor
that has so much value because you've
got all these different strategies and
then you sit in front of a vendor and
you say how can I help and then you find
the best strategy for them which is when
when you make money they get out of the
problem so it's perfect and you can make
so much money doing that well well this
is it and look it gives us a I think as
long as you're doing it properly using
making sure the vendor gets independent
legal and financial exactly yeah and
it's aboveboard and you're showing
integrity then this is an incredible
strategy to use you have a very powerful
thing to have in your toolbox it is and
property is a good vehicle it is can
make a lot of money help a lot of people
absolutely so what your visions are over
the next 12 months
my vision over the next 12 months is
continue buying property I'm looking
quite a few
been looking at building properties but
there's been a slight change in the cost
of building and land
Yakima's ition but I am just
accelerating as much as I can
you've got five deals going through
right at the moment and they're all
purchases yes that's incredible a
scalable so again I want more so I'm
looking at more stuff every day
yeah I'm scanning right move I've got a
lot of friends that want to invest in me
as well so happy rights really it
doesn't stop as you know you get on a
roll and you go what what best advice
would you give to somebody that was
saying I want to be where you're at I
want to be in a position where everyone
wants to invest with me and I'm got five
deals going through it what would be
your best best advice I mean that is a
great question all right now I've mented
somewhere over 350 property investors
that question remind me of one all right
one person who sat and said that many
things I want to be successful like you
so I asked him about he's doing what
he's doing and he said well I work and I
get home from work around about 6
o'clock and then I has a bit of dinner
and I said what do you do then he's in
the had a city look on his face and he
said well you know what's a bit of telly
so I said he watching the soaps and he
said yeah so which one's in and he was
watching all of them now the next month
I was doing this for a property company
so he wasn't my own mentee anyway he
came back the next month and I said so
how's it going how many properties have
you seen and he said I was seeing four
so I said look this is it really easy
I'm getting right down your homework for
this month and it said go home throw
your TV in the rubbish yeah all right so
the answer to the question Samuel is are
you ready to pay the price is what is
your motivation love it are you ready to
improve your mind with education and are
you ready to put the the work in and the
the shoe-leather to go and do it because
as you know when you start I always
remember dinner honey
remember dinner honey no she was a very
clever lady she was in debt and she went
to network meeting she found invested
who were gonna back her from her
investment so she had money behind us
going by she went out and saw 200
properties and she ended up getting six
deals under market value well under
about 30
and the market value really good once
now when people say how many properties
do I need to be you to get one deal I've
always used that as a yardstick when you
start yeah 3333 you've you 33 properties
and you make offers yeah then I think
you'll get the deal yeah when you
starting off now you and I it's much
less we have a lower football because we
know what we're looking at is that going
to work or not but when you start you
gotta pay the piper
yeah I love that brilliant advice get
rid of the TV get around the right
people let's get trained up and stop
doing some houses that's it
that's great and you are such a giving
person I love that you're you're so
successful you're able to make so much
money in property but you still give
back teach people what you know because
you but you believe in it what would the
best wave someones get in touch with you
I've got a website it's table of 1200 UK
my email is probably best which is
Trevor at table of 1200 UK 12 is written
in letters it is not a number so table
of 12 code at UK Trevor you're amazing
thanks so much for coming on the show
hope you've enjoyed it I have thank you
for having me good seeing you again
think like guys don't forget to Like
subscribe and share the video and look
forward to seeing you next time thank
you so much for watching if you
benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time